ja also ich habe mich heute den ganzen
tag eigentlich wollte ich gar nicht ob
ich mich aufgeregt über gerhard schröder
ja schön dass sie in sich das war mal
unser bundeskanzler und ich fand den
damals ganz gut achtung zeit für ein
geständnis ich habe den mann sogar mal
gewählt und vielleicht bin ich deshalb
so wütend was jetzt aus ihm geworden ist
und was er da an stellt mit wladimir
putin und mit seiner lobbytätigkeit bei
gazprom da ist er jetzt im aufsichtsrat
und das finde ich in der sache
vielleicht noch hinnehmbar
aber in den finanzen unanständig denn
gerd schröder wird ja alimentiert von
unserem geld von meinem geld von ihrem
geld von dem geld aus unserer runde mit
steuergeldern bekommt der ganz
ordentliche privilegien bezahlt das ist
auch ganz okay im büro limousine
natürlichen fahrer mitarbeiter man sagt
so ungefähr eine viertel million im jahr
kostet das alles zusammen jetzt nimmt
aber eine million euro sagt man als
gehalt im aufsichtsrat von gazprom also
indirekt von wladimir putin das bedeutet
wir deutschen zahlen einen finanzieren
einen lobbyisten der gegen deutschland
arbeitet und von dort lässt er sich auch
noch geld gibt und das finde ich
wirklich nicht nur für die
sozialdemokraten sondern für einen
anständigen menschen schwierig und mein
vorschlag würde lauten ich will jetzt
gar nicht weiter auf die palme sondern
ich komme schon wieder runter gekrabbelt
und sagen herr schröder sie haben hartz
4 erfunden sie haben hat es hier
eingeführt jeder hartz 4 empfänger wer
also zu seinem staatlichen geld was
dazuverdient da wird es angerechnet und
verrechnet und das fordere ich auch von
ihnen geben sie uns unser geld zurück
solange sie eine million von putin
kriegen zahlen sie die viertel millionen
im jahr zurück solange diese eine
million fließt ich finde das sind sie
deutschland schuldig also darf ich
darauf antworten klar da habe ich eine
gespaltene antwort der erste teil ist
also im deutschen rechtssystem gibt es
das prinzip der rache nicht also man
kommt damit nicht durch wände ansprüche
auf pensionen kriegt er die kann man
aber gesetzlich verändern was ich aber
sagen wollte ist dass er gegen
deutschland arbeitet kann man nicht
sagen deutschland bezieht mehr als die
hälfte seines gasverbrauchs auch
russland deutschland bezieht oder
generiert fast die hälfte seines benzins
aus russischem öl da sitzt ja nicht nur
schröder sitzt nur bei gazprom sondern
auch bei ross neff dass der ölkonzern im
verwaltungsrat neben bp brings also wenn
wir das gebrauchen und verbrauchen und
kein wort darüber verlieren dass da
beschwert sich ja keiner das ist zu viel
wir wollen jetzt umsteigen in den
quellen usw dann kann es nicht falsch
sein dass er in deutschland in
aufsichtsgremien den lieferanten sitzt
und wenn wir den bundeskanzler jetzt
treten weil er nicht in moskau war der
muss unbedingt mit putin sprechen kann
man auch nicht den früheren kanzler
dafür bestrafen dass ein draht zu putin
hat erster teil der antwort zwei
parteien richtig ist aber wenn einer
einen riesen ankunft hat müssen
natürlich pensionen und anderes
gegengerechnet werden und zwar nicht nur
bei schröder sondern gerne welten es
müsste man mal gesetzlich verändern also
ich will was zudem erstens in dem
ländlichen ersten teil seiner nachdem
nachdem ich in der ersten hälfte der
sendung gedacht habe du bist ein fanboy
von christian lindner jetzt es war ein
gewisser eigentlich
hätte mir früher auffallen können aber
bei ob das das vorweg ich finde dass man
natürlich das argumentieren kann dass
jemand wenn wird dort rohstoffe beziehen
darauf aufpasst und unsere und unsere
interessen vertritt mein eindruck ist
aber nicht dass unsere interessen
vertreten werden sondern mein eindruck
ist dass bei einem druckmittel von putin
nämlich ich bin euer lieferant beim
gegner im ukraine konflikt ausgerechnet
weil ich sag jetzt mal wirklich
persönlich ehemaliger bundeskanzler dem
gegner auf dem schluss sitzt und dieses
symbolik die finde ich wirklich
problematisch und die hielt mich darüber
auf weil alle haben bei gerhard schröder
ja schon als er im amt war immer gesagt
naja gut also der es halt ein schlingel
der ist ein schlawiner und der verdient
auch gern geld und wartet mal ab wenn er
danach und ich habe immer gesagt nee dem
geht's am ende schon um den
sozialdemokratischen gedanken dem geht
es am ende schon um die leute in
deutschland und jetzt muss ich
feststellen er darf noch mal kaum ist ja
nicht mehr kanzler geht es ihm doch nur
um sein bankkonto und ich würde dieses
gegenrechnen ich finde das können wir
als initiative von heute auf ihr es aber
etwas anderes sagen ich weiß dass es
wahrscheinlich eine übermenschliche
anforderung ist und jeder muss bevor sie
aufstellt mal eben sich selber
einreichen gerhard schröder könnte
sozusagen diesen ganze kritik nicht nur
abfedern sondern kainz gegenteil wenden
wenn er erklären würde ich habe jetzt
hier einnahmen über die spekulieren alle
und es ist eigentlich sogar für
ja und deshalb so lange das so ist
verzichte ich auf die zahlungen
oder richtig ja also sozusagen das ist
wie ich auch finde menschen die viel
verdienen könnten auch auf kindergeld
verzichten ja also es ist sozusagen eine
art eine art wie anstand oder oder
gefühl für eine solide haben einfach
immer über solidargemeinschaften zu
quatschen und wenn es darum geht sich
der solidargemeinschaft nach oben zu
entziehen das regt mich darauf ich finde
ist dass dieser ganze herrlichkeit von
schröder dieses ganze was ich jetzt ja
gerade versucht schlecht 2008 er sprach
mich total an ihm habe ich vertraut er
hat auch bisweilen gute politik also und
jetzt macht er da so kommt auch unter
stress könnte ich allein
ich habe
da könnte ja sagen von den von meiner
pension bezahle ich die heizkosten in
diesem jahr von 1000 berlin an doch
schon mal was
in einer sache widersprechen das ist
nicht ein einseitiges druck verhältnis
russlands uns gegenüber die russen sind
auf ihrer gerne exporte existenziell
angewiesen eigentlich noch mehr als wir
auf die importe denn ich glaube drei
viertel des staatshaushalts bestehen die
haben ja sonst wirtschaftlich nichts
zustande gebracht während die
regierungszeit von putin die können nur
rohstoffe exportieren wenn sie das nicht
mehr können haben sie ein riesenproblem
also insofern können die uns auch nicht
einfach abschnüren dass da tun sie sich
selbst mit schadenfrohen ich verstehe
schon dass da jetzt wieder auf die
sachebene
erleben wir aber doch schon zu wenn wir
erweitern jetzt mal noch um den ganzen
server basieren doch herr schröder auch
oft erlebt sie haben auch in die bunte
damals eingeführt dass auch politiker
porträtiert werde auch über sie
berichtet wird herr schröder hat sich
sein oder ein getränk
heute war
ich
meinen strom und gas in dem boden war
aachen hat sozusagen ein geschenk konnte
man sie überhaupt nicht vorstellen in
der redaktion kursierte ja das schöne
spruch der hat ein henkel am kopf her
und bdv kann ihn davon tragen wenn
der
amerikanische also eine amerikanische
gehabt jahren mit mit mitte frau und
seiner seite und erstmal damit seine ein
erster richtiger großer auftritt war mit
helau pottschalk und da wurde darüber
gesprochen was passiert wenn er nicht
treu ist und ich glaube hier oder ein
gewehr auf trab brennt die hütte
ich meine ja politiker hat es jemals
zuvor gesagt wobei man ja über viele
politiker und ihr privatleben was sagen
könnte nicht serielle monogamie ich
glaube diese begriffliche
hinter nike ist es gibt keine
schnittmengen das habe ich das immer
verstand so dass darin was möchte ich
jetzt nicht reden aber
wir wissen sie sind weitgehend leer wenn
das anders gemacht hätte er damit seinem
leben gespielt also höchstens in der
allerletzten schlussphase einer ehe hat
dann museums neues angefangen haben war
so aber das war dann schnell
eine tolle rhein mit seinen anzügen
seine zigarre region in einer festen ja
ich meine ich habe mir manchmal erlebt
wenn er dann gerne
laufe des abends wenn es ein bisschen
länger dauert die capri fischer singt
uns euch gesagt sein beim ersten tender
rotwein getrunken
weil ich im transferbereich friesi
menschen mit dem begriff nichts anfangen
so ungefähr 120 euro die flasche
kann man ganz schön viel heizen dafür
ein charmanter typ sehr männlich und der
öffentlichkeit zugewandt ja und lässt
auch gern ein bisschen hineingucken und
meint sein privatleben ist wirklich
aufregend das muss man schon sagen ja
und so gesehen hat er frau hat am
scharfen schwert gehöre ja ich kann
gesagt auch wenn man ist vielleicht
teuer ist gleich ohne putins polen
gedenkt wenn man schröder hatte ich mein
politiker ja war die auflage immer okay
ich meine also jetzt kann man von
anderen politiker
[Gelächter]
friedrich bulla stolz privat
es gab in buntem vor kurzem auch ein
bericht über olaf scholz und seine frau
aber auf den titel hat das nicht
olaf scholz geht am sonntag nicht
brötchen und dann ein halbes
vollkornbrot dazu gehört auch das ist
ein gewaltiges nochmal gar eine alm ist
also für den real tragen wie denn dazu
also sollte jetzt herr schröder
verzichten unser altkanzler oder worüber
reden wir eigentlich absolut ich bin
absolut mit den beiden herren dekor es
ist ja so dass politiker natürlich die
goldene drehtür nutzen nach ihrem
politischen karriere und sich das
vergolden lassen dann finde ich super
okay ja ich bin ja ich muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen herr gabriel der deutschen
bank im aufsichtsrat
habe also es gibt es gibt es sollte eine
karenzzeit geben und es sollte
tatsächlich auch so was wie eine
anrechnung geben dass man sagt okay der
rückstand war bei der zeit ja zum weiter
jetzt besser gefallen ja aber alles gibt
halt einfach eine gewisse würde die
dieses amt auch in sich trägt und dann
wirtschaftsminister war für die
arbeiterpartei spd geht danach nicht zur
deutschen bank deshalb doch er sei
wirklich kein stil muss ich sie und
dahin gehen
putin oder
ich finde die idee dass man strategische
liefern uns mit mit öl und gas was wir
auch wirklich brauchen vor allem in
zeiten wie diesen wo liga sprach
speicher leer sind gar nicht so schlecht
und warum hat man sich nicht mit denen
gut stehen stellen also dahin gehen
fällt jetzt nichts verwerfliches eines
tages nochmal den draht zu putin den
persönlichen kann man lässt genossen
mehr weiß dass mit der ukraine noch
alles passieren
der retter den deutschen er hat dann
immer am telefon dass gerade von cummins
sind die haben auch promis wie sie beide
und dahin gehen ist es gar nicht
schlecht da auch mal den direkten draht
zu haben tatsächlich ja du bist
amputiert